[Music]
snow and soul on the streets of Tallinn
where there's little doubt about the top
defence priority deterring the threat
posed by neighboring Russia Britain's
armed forces play a role in this as part
of a NATO mission but planning for a
possible No Deal brexit is taking up
more and more of the military's time the
Estonian Foreign Minister is confident
his allies will rise to the challenge
I'm pretty confident that they will be
able to handle the the national security
issues at the time of even no direction
that happened Sky News can reveal the
top civil servant at the Ministry of
Defense has said preparing for a
withdrawal from the European Union
without a deal is his department's
highest priority in a letter Stephan
Lovegrove told officers and civil
servants to implement the remaining
elements of their no deal plans without
delay details of the military's
contingency preparations include
selecting around 3,000 soldiers who make
up most of the three and a half thousand
military personnel ready for No Deal
duties some of these troops could
already be on alert to respond to a
military crisis overseas military
facilities might be required to store
Freight or accommodate extra personnel
and the return of more than 6,000
soldiers and their families from Germany
could face disruption though the lod
says there are currently no delays it's
understood the Armed Forces will conduct
a number of war games to test their
readiness for a No Deal brexit in the
coming days while also continuing to
defend the UK and its allies from
security threats personnel are due to
travel here to Estonia this summer to
take part in a joint expeditionary force
exercise that plan will go ahead even if
troops are still needed back home to
deal with brexit issues the strain could
show however if the UK is forced to face
multiple demands at the same time this
could be in the form of brexit
disruption a terrorist attack and an
emergency abroad the Ministry of Defence
says plans are being prepared to ensure
a no deal brexit doesn't affect the
military or its commitments including in
Estonia
mr. love groves letter however reveals
some areas of mo D work may have to be
delayed European allies will be watching
to see what happens next
Deborah Haynes Sky News Tallinn